Mr Speaker with with apologies with
apologies to the leader of the
opposition and the house the piano is
detained on urgent business
and
and they will they will have to make do
I must hear the answer of why the prime
minister's not here
I'm afraid you'll have to make do with
me Mr Speaker the the Prime Minister has
taken the decision to point my right
honorable friend the member for
Southwest Surrey one of the longest
serving and most experienced
parliamentarians as her Chancellor
[Music]
they're overriding priority is to
restore Financial stability in the face
of volatile Global conditions we will
take whatever tough decisions are
necessary and have made changes to the
great plan which the chancellor
which the chancellor is waiting to
update the house on as soon as this
urgent question finishes
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you to
the right honorable member for
Portsmouth North for answering the
question put to the Prime Minister I
guess under this Tory government
everybody gets to be prime minister for
15 minutes
the country
Mr Speaker the countries in an economic
crisis made in Downing Street because
they
thought that all credibility government
borrowing costs have sword mortgage
rates have ballooned markets need
reassuring
and there is long-term damage
the car at 100 miles an hour you've
damaged it for good and you're going to
be paying much more on your insurance
for years to come and it's working
people who will pay left wondering if
they can afford to stay in their homes
if their hopes of owning a home haven't
already been crushed so now it's time
for leaders to lead but where is the
prime minister
[Applause]
hiding away dodging questions scared of
our own shadow the laid is not for
turning up
now it's time to be honest about the
mistakes they made yeah but what does
the Prime Minister say my vision is
right my mission remains I sack my
Chancellor but I can't tell you why
and now is a time for consistent
messaging but what do we get a prime
minister saying absolutely no spending
reductions a Chancellor saying there
will be cuts a prime minister saying
she's in charge a chancellor who thinks
he's the CEO and she's just the chair
yeah yeah how can Britain get the
stability it needs when all the
government offers is grotesque chaos how
can Britain get the stability it needs
when instead of leadership we have this
utter vacuum yeah how can Britain get
the stability it needs when the Prime
Minister has no mandate from her party
adds no mandate from the country
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker let me start by
saying I'm quite quietly confident that
the leader of the opposition will not
have his 15 minutes
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
with regard to questions raised on
economic policy I will defer to the
chancellor honorable member
memorable members will want time to
question him fully
fully tale I do not wish to eat into
that time our constituents will want to
hear about the issues facing them their
bills mortgages benefits and their
businesses so I had wondered just what
else the league of the opposition wished
to discuss in this uq that would delay
such an important statement in his in
his urgent question he paints a contrast
so let me paint one too
the decision taken by our prime minister
would have been a very tough one
politically
[Music]
and she has so
she has done so because it is manifestly
in the National interest that she did
not hesitate to do so because her focus
is on the well-being of every one of our
citizens
it was the right thing to do and whether
you agree with it or not it
courage to do it
the trust
in contrast what the right honorable
gentleman has done today
this most serious moment took no courage
or
dment
or regard to the National interest
[Applause]
the go Mr Speaker
three years ago when this Parliament was
paralyzed by brexit a general election
would have been in the National interest
and he blocked it
[Applause]
today when the country needs some
stability and Urgent legislation to put
through cost of living measures and
while we are in the middle of an
economic War leveled at every school and
Hospital in this country he now calls
for one and weeks of disruption and
delay
we will take no lectures from The
Honorable Gentleman on working in the
National interest
[Applause]
I could point to his frustration of us
leaving the EU and campaigning for a
second referendum
port for the right honorable member for
Islington North and
ersons on NATO all his arguments against
us leaving lockdown or are involvement
for the EU vaccines agency
all against the national interest
and nor will we take any lectures on
consistency of policy or messaging
[Applause]
that woman has abandoned
and pledges during the labor leadership
contest
[Applause]
[Music]
I think the country also wants to hear
what's being said if I can't hear their
country so can we please listen to
leaders I'm sure it's coming to the end
now through the house I am Mr Speaker
which is why even on Earth Mr Perkins if
you want to go get a cup of tea I'm more
than happy to pay for it
yes why Mr Speaker
on our toughest and most disappointing
days I will always be proud to sit on
this side of the house